first and foremost congrats on season
three season one was a huge breakout hit
and very successful season two in my
opinion topped it
so moving forward into season three
sholo tell me um
has it exceeded your own expectations
i think so you know uh i feel like
season three really goes to show just
how
uh once you have established your
characters and kind of
set this universe that everyone's
supposed to live in how you can start to
then push the barriers and and really
because i feel like season one was
really establishing
what would johnny be like in 2018 and
what would daniel be like in 2018 and
once you kind of establish those worlds
then you need a conflict and i feel like
they established that in season two and
that was crease
and you know how he uh you know took
over
cobra kai and now in season three now
you gotta deal with that conflict so i
feel like
this season is definitely the most
action-packed
and i think this is where we're we're
definitely gonna see
uh the the big boys it taken out and uh
you know uh everyone's gonna come with
their best foot forward
i love that uh jacob in season two i
feel like hawk got
a lot more dark a lot more dangerous
um tell me moving into season three what
are hawk's motivations and does he even
get
even darker if that's possible um
you know i hate to say it but i will
tease that hawk
does go a little bit darker before he
hits it's hits the light side
uh you know now he's with creases cobra
kai
and you know he's under his uh influence
he definitely has his fangs sinked into
his neck
um so i think a big struggle for hawk
this season is uh just kind of finding
where
where he fits into this new dojo and you
know miguel isn't in
obviously because he's you know dead
miguel isn't in
cover kai anymore and you know his
ex-best friend binary brother dimitri is
no longer with him so
he's just kind of like finding where he
fits in in all this yeah um
show low you know we obviously saw that
miguel
is injured um and the trailer kind of
teased us
tell me about his road to recovery
because you know
it's gonna be a tough one for him i
think yeah
i think the road to recovery is not one
that is just going to be solved
you know in a finger snap it's not a
it's something that's a going to take a
lot of
searching within himself to figure out
uh
i think when when an event like this
happens you you can't help but question
did i do the wrong thing you know are
the people around me really the people
that i want to be around me
and i think that's going to be a
question that we hear miguel asking a
lot
and you know not to mention his ride or
die
the person that he looks up to the most
johnny gave him information that
inevitably put him in this position so i
think
you know there is going to be a little
bit of resentment and a little uh you
know chip on his shoulder in terms of
trying to
wrink reconvene with johnny and his mom
will definitely have something to say
about that
but uh you know as someone who
really enjoys the the scenes with
billy and and i really enjoy the johnny
and miguel relationship
i hope that it is just a small blip in
the large scheme of things but
we'll see maybe chris has uh some other
things in plan
he just may uh jacob fans noticed in the
trailer that your moon tattoo
has been covered up with a grim reaper
tattoo
listen i'm the type of person that
always wants people to find
happiness will hawk move on from moon
will he find maybe a new love
uh i don't know um that's a really good
question
uh that's the you're actually the first
person who's mentioned the grim reaper
tat today so
kudos to you yeah
uh yeah um i think
hawk has things to figure out in his own
head before he can be emotionally
available to
start dating again honestly um that dude
needs to take some time off
i think honestly i think everyone in the
freaking show needs to take some time
to figure themselves out a little bit
where they jump back out and start
dating you know
i would agree with that i gotta wrap
this up thank you guys so much and
congrats on season three
tim hortons man yeah double double